[Music]
on this Sunday night should Quebec delay
reopening concerns over the test the
province is relying on to get back in
business and didn't perform well and
Canada's plans to increase the supply of
PPE a disturbing trend between kovat 19
and the ethnic population in the u.s.
the mission to boost morale
Canada snowbirds embarked on an
inspirational cross-country tour and the
love affair that didn't reveal itself
for 60 years the 1940s it was dangerous
now the subject of a Canadian
documentary
[Music]
global national with Robin Gil
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin tonight with a setback for
testing of kovat 19 across this country
an auto a biotech company is voluntarily
recalling a rapid test for the virus
after Health Canada raised concerns
about its effectiveness the Spartan test
was called a game-changer and provinces
were depending on it as they lay out
plans to reopen for business
Michael couture has our top story
tonight it's a diagnosis in the pollen
her head it was touted as a quick test
for kovat 19 without having to send
samples to a lab but ottawa-based
spartan bioscience is recalling its
handheld DNA analyzer after Health
Canada expressed concerns about the
company's proprietary swabs while the
Spartan system or the device performed
very well in a laboratory setting and
along the saying that specifications
that the manufacturer had provided it
was in the real-life setting in the
clinical setting where it didn't perform
well dr. Tam doesn't believe this will
affect the national testing goal of
60,000 Canadians a day but it could
affect the speed of testing in rural or
remote areas a Spartan bioscience
declined our request for an interview
but said in a statement the same report
indicated no concerns regarding the
accuracy and analytical performance of
Spartans test reagents and portable DNA
analyzer device adding they will work as
quickly as possible to address the
concerns and bring its test to market
and there's pressure to act fast Ontario
Alberta and Quebec had earmarked
millions of dollars to buy the Spartan
test kits while at the same time
promising to ramp up testing as they
reopen their economies so with testing
still limited the federal government is
putting a focus on personal protective
equipment with the creation of a new
covet 19 supply council as the economy
starts to open in different places in
different ways it is going to be
important to have even more personal
protective equipment for people working
in the private sector in various
industries the council's job will be to
find solutions to build innovative and
agile supply chains to maintain Canada's
stockpile of medical equipment like
ventilators masks and other PPE
this is procurement like it's never been
done before for that very reason we need
to be planning for the short and the
long term and all eventualities
including a possible second surge of
kovat 19 as provinces start to reopen
for business
Michael cooter global news Ottawa so far
in Canada nearly 1 million Canadians
have been tested for Cova 19 over 59,000
cases have come back positive for the
virus since the outbreak began more than
3,600 people have died there is more
financial help for Canadian families an
increase to the Canada Child Benefit
anyone receiving a CCB check this month
will see an extra $300 per child
eligible families will see this one-time
increase as part of the scheduled May
payment the federal government says this
is part of a two billion dollar Relief
Fund to help families with the cost of
taking care of their kids during this
crisis Britain's Prime Minister is
revealing more about his dramatic close
call with Kovan 19:00 Boris Johnson says
contingency plans were put in place in
case he died at one point it was 50/50
whether or not doctors would put him on
a ventilator Johnson didn't have to go
that route but was given leaders and
leaders of oxygen while undergoing
treatment in intensive care he also
admitted he didn't take the disease
seriously enough and was forced to go to
hospital on the advice of doctors in the
u.s. there's concern tonight as 34
states relax restrictions and many
Americans get ready to head back to work
over a million people have been infected
with kovat 19 in the u.s. more than 67
thousand people have died that's more
than any other country as the numbers
spike across the US the Trump
administration claims there is evidence
Kovan 19 originated in a lab in China as
Jennifer Johnson reports it's fueling
tension about how
outbreak has been handled the Trump
administration is again pointing the
finger at China US Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo claims there is evidence the
Cova 19 virus came from a Wuhan lab but
isn't providing any proof for his claims
President Trump is very clear we're
going to hold those responsible
accountable and we'll do so on a
timeline that our is our own Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau is not ready to
say exactly how this started we continue
to work very closely with our partners
and allies and indeed independently on
many security issues that are important
for Canadians at this point we are not
drawing any firm conclusions American
intelligence agencies are continuing to
investigate whether a lab in China was
the origin for this deadly pandemic
meanwhile from crowded beaches to reopen
walls to protests across the u.s. more
and more Americans are shoulder to
shoulder no protective masks abandoning
social distancing rules it's in God's
hands what happens to me in my house
White House coronavirus Task Force
members are sounding the alarm
it's devastatingly worrisome to me
personally because if they go home and
infect their grandmother or their
grandfather they will feel guilty for
the rest of our lives but some
governor's say they can't stop residents
from not playing by the rules in Ohio a
complete about-face the governor first
ordered shoppers to wear masks then
reversed his rule people were not going
to accept the government telling them
what to do and so we put out you know
dozens and dozens of orders that was one
that it just went too far in Georgia one
of the first states to reopen residents
showing little concern a crowded indoor
malls and outdoor parks even as it's
kovat 19 death rate continues to
increase it's a little shocking to see
so many people just disregarding human
life not wearing protective
not saying six feet apart stayin home
and mean social distance has saved life
if this pattern continues doctors and
nurses on the front lines fear another
surge in cases Jennifer Johnson Global
News Washington we've been told that
everyone is susceptible to cope at 19
but in the u.s. doctors are seeing a
stark divide in who's getting sick
ethnic communities are especially
vulnerable in this outbreak as Jackson
prosecco reports experts believe
historic inequities are to blame across
the u.s.
doctors and nurses have noticed a
disturbing trend when it comes to who's
ending up in emergency rooms people of
color are being hit disproportionately
hard bykova at 19 I'm surprising the
magnitude of the end it's really really
obviously more to people of color in
Chicago african-americans account for
67% of coronavirus deaths despite making
up just 32 percent of the city's
population it's the same story in
Louisiana where Gary Harrell has lost 10
family members and friends you can't
ignore it so much what I see is COBIT 19
exposing in a very stark fashion us
racism dr. Kamara Jones is an
epidemiologist at Harvard and says
decades of inequality are taking their
toll on communities that have less
access to healthcare in populations with
more underlying health conditions
there's another factor too they don't
have the kinds of jobs you know on the
hole where they can just shelter in
place and work from home they're doing
the front-facing home health care aid
bus driving sanitation work maintenance
work in the hospitals 84 percent of
Latinos in the u.s. work in essential
jobs in some states Latinos are
contracting coronavirus at a rate three
times higher than average Jose Gonzalez
says there's pressure to take any work
we don't have the benefit of I should
just stay home to you know not carry on
that such a high risk and I feel like
that's every Latino at this point cities
across the u.s. have now begun to
consider
race as part of coronavirus statistics
using that to better target resources in
Baltimore that's led to a push to get
information out the messaging the Public
Health guidance just simply was not
penetrating certain segments of our
community communities that have been hit
exceptionally hard by a virus that has
taken an enormous toll Jackson Proust Co
Global News Washington
communication is key to getting vital
information out during this pandemic
that's why we are seeing daily updates
from Canada's political and health
leaders but there are other key players
in those briefings the interpreters for
the deaf and that's one of the stories
on our special series the new reality
which airs tonight our mic relay is here
with a sneak preview of the critical
role they play Mike Robin they say
information is king and that's never
been more true we're getting daily kovin
19 updates in both official languages
but if you're deaf it's hit or miss now
you may have seen stories in the news
over the past month on interpreters
there have been a lot nigel howard NBC
has a fan page and a guy in the US has
developed a following because he looks
like David Letterman he's the same guy
by the way who signed a Beyonce concert
last year but on this story the media
has missed the mark
because while interpreters are animated
they're really just speaking their
language so the real issue is like
accessibility that have plagued the deaf
community for years are being overlooked
in favor of entertainment so tonight on
the new reality we take a deeper dive
into American Sign Language and how a
quiet world just got a whole lot quieter
for the deaf community Robin all right
thanks for that Mike and you can watch
Mike story tonight at 7:00 p.m. on our
special series coronavirus the new
reality hosted by Donna freezin coming
up on global national those living in
Alberta's flood zone may not be able to
rely on insurance
you
there's tension tonight after North
Korea and South Korea exchanged gunfire
for the first time since 2017 according
to South Korea North Korea fired first
the bullets crossed the demilitarized
zone hitting a guard post in a central
border town South Korea shot back and
issued a warning via loudspeaker there
was no further gunfire US intelligence
suggests the North's attack was likely a
mistake according to a South Korean
official Kim jong-un did not undergo
surgery or any other medical procedure
there's been a lot of speculation about
the dictators health including rumors of
a heart operation but here he was
yesterday smiling during a Labor Day
celebration some observers noted his
walk looked a bit stiff the prime
minister says more gun restrictions are
on the way amid criticism his government
didn't go far enough with its ban on
1,500 types of military-style assault
weapons that includes steps that could
lead to prohibitions on handguns we know
that there is more to do on
strengthening gun control in this
country which is why we're going to be
moving forward when Parliament allows it
with stronger measures around borders
stronger measures around safe storage
measures around handguns to permit
municipalities to ban handguns within
their city limits but conservative
leaders like Alberta's Jason Kenney
accuse Trudeau of targeting law-abiding
gun owners they should take though
though that effort and those resources
and focus on stopping the widespread
smuggling of illegal firearms across the
canada-us border and so we're very
disappointed that they're that they're
in the middle of his pandemic I think
focused on the politics of this and
going about it in the wrong way Trudeau
made an election promise to ban
military-style assault weapons he moved
ahead with it in the wake of that mass
killing that claimed the lives of 22
people in nova scotia two weeks ago in
Fort McMurray
floodwaters have receded and the damage
is being uncovered as Global's Brianna
Karstens Smith reports in a neighborhood
devastated by wildfires four years ago
insurance may not cover the cost of
recovery a second time around this is
the waterways neighborhood in Lower Fort
McMurray four years ago today 90% of the
homes here were destroyed by fire when
the Wildfire came into the city forcing
everyone out now fast forward to this
week and its water that's taken over and
damaged pretty much every home in this
neighborhood once again a lot of these
residents losing their home twice in
just four years
those were speaking with are saying that
the flooding is worse than the fire
their insurance covered the fire damage
and it does not look like it will be
covered for the water damage they are
now forced to try and save anything they
can and figure out how to rebuild we've
also been seeing some cleanup in
downtown Fort McMurray that's where some
of the big-box stores are that will be
needed to help clean up and rebuild
we're seeing the Walmart the Canadian
Tire aronia all closed and now doing
their own cleanup we spoke with Mayor
John Scott who says that he will be
asking both the provincial and federal
governments for financial assistance to
help the residents recover from this
we've also been speaking with fire chief
Jody Butz he says they really had to
shift gears to go from fire to flood to
rescue more than two hundred people this
week who were not obeying mandatory
evacuation orders so a big change for
him but he says starting Monday they are
back to fire response because the
wildfire season has started here in this
region and despite all the water it does
look that the risk will be quite high
again this year reporting from Fort
McMurray frana Carsten Smith global news
still ahead
secret no more a love hidden for decades
is now in the spotlight
you are watching global national coming
out as LGBTQ to is still not an easy
decision in the case of a Saskatchewan
couple their love was hidden for decades
now Terry Donahue and Pat hensel's life
together is the subject of a documentary
produced by a family member
Eric Sorenson has their story it's a
love affair so unusual it was hidden
behind a facade for more than 60 years
Terry Donahue and Pat Henschel were
Saskatchewan farm girls when they met
until I met Pat I don't know what
happened but that was it they fell in
love
moved to the US and told the world they
were cousins anybody who was not he they
simply didn't know a new documentary
chronicles their story from a friend
first warning Terry about women in
relationships she said I just wanna let
you know what goes on so you're aware of
it - Antarian had finally had the
courage to tell their families and
they've always been a neat area auntie
Pat didn't know they were gay till three
years ago
what's so acceptable today was fraught
with risk in the 1940s living as they
did and the parties they went to could
have landed them in jail Terry Donahue
nephew made the film I think it's a very
special kind of love and you know coming
from the time they came from the 1940s
it was dangerous very dangerous so the
fact that they stayed true to who were
they were and listened to their hearts I
think is an incredible story a story
made more incredible because Terry was a
baseball star in an era when women's pro
balls sprang up in minor league towns
across the American Midwest because most
men had gone to war
Terry played for the Peoria Red Wings
made to wear skirts a code of conduct
that brought even more deception always
appear in feminine attire no slacks or
shorts in public longer hair preferred
lipstick always on and the skirts well
not too short
Hollywood told the baseball story with a
light touch but it reflected the reality
for women ballplayers always chaperoned
even made to go to Charm School Terry
said she liked breaking the rules
they were playing baseball women didn't
do that Terry and Pat were trailblazers
to women in love living and working in
Chicago for decades they married just
five years ago I wanted to show the
younger generation today that that the
shoulders that they are standing on came
from these pioneers these groundbreakers
with health issues the couple moved back
to Canada Pat found some old love notes
she'd written to Terry was one night I
shall remember one more night to call
our own Terry Donahue died last year Pat
and Terry's love affair lasted more than
70 years fortunately it was only a
secret 460 Eric Sorensen Global News
Toronto
up next the sky-high effort to boost
Canadian morale in times of tragedy
the devastation felt from the mass
killing in Nova Scotia Will's already
compounded by the Cova 19 crisis but
then another tragedy occurred the loss
of six members of the Canadian Forces
who died in a helicopter crash off the
coast of Greece to say Canadians are in
need of a morale boost right now is an
understatement but there's a mission
underway to lift spirits across the
country the snowbirds took off this
morning for operation inspiration flying
over Nova Scotia and New Brunswick
they'll make their way right across the
country to honor all Canadians doing
their part in the kovat 19 pandemic but
as Mike Armstrong explains Operation
inspiration kicks off on an important
day in Canada's military history now
this is what should have been on a
normal first Sunday in May hundreds on
hand at the National War Memorial in
Ottawa to commemorate the end of the
Battle of the Atlantic instead it was
this a video shared by the Royal
Canadian Navy on Facebook just two
members and a single wreath the Battle
of the Atlantic cost the lives of 1,600
merchant seamen 750 Airmen and close to
2,000 Canadian sailors it was Canada's
longest military engagement six years
spent fighting German u-boats keeping
allied supply lines to Europe open today
marks the 75th anniversary of the Battle
of the Atlantic as we remember the
sailors soldiers and pilots who helped
turn the tide of the Second World War we
honor all our veterans who step forward
so we may live in peace Royal Canadian
Navy moved the commemorations of this
anniversary on line ships shared videos
Sunday of their services this was HMCS
Winnipeg
this was HMCS Moncton commemoration was
not the one they're used to now at every
ceremony this year there are heavy
hearts at the National War Memorial by
that lone wreath a reminder that the
sacrifice of those in uniform continues
photographs of the six members of the
Canadian Armed Forces killed this week
in a helicopter crash off the coast of
Greece these six members played paid
that ultimate sacrifice the six were
remembered in a memorial at the gates of
Nova Scotia's CFB Shearwater it's the
downed helicopters home base the event
was organized by a veterans group one of
the Fallen sailors was a member sub
leftenant Abigail Cobra she was a ray of
sunshine she she was a beautiful
beautiful person and so young 23 now the
Shearwater gates was one of the first
flyovers for the snowbirds Sunday as
they kicked off their cross-canada tour
Mike Armstrong Global News Montreal and
that is global national for this Sunday
I'm Robin Gill we leave you tonight with
more of today's stunning flybys thank
you for watching
[Music]